Наймасованіші обстріли Києва з боку Росії, починаючи з 24 лютого.
В понеділок вранці вибухи лунали також у Дніпрі, Житомирі, Хмельницькому, Тернополі,
Вінниці, Кривому Розі, Львові, Обухові та інших населених пунктах -
загалом по всій території України вранці понеділка Росія
випустила під сотню ракет.
Окрім масованих ракетних та авіаційних ударів,
Росія застосовує ударні безпілотники.
Ранок важкий. Маємо справу з терористами.
Десятки ракет, іранські "Шахіди". У них дві мішені.
Енергообʼєкти - по всій державі. Вони прагнуть паніки і хаосу.
Хочуть знищити нашу енергосистему. Вони безнадійні.
Друга мішень - люди. Спеціально обрали такий час і такі цілі,
щоб завдати якнайбільше шкоди.
За даними прем'єр-міністра України Дениса Шмигаля,
внаслідок російських ракетних ударів пошкоджено,
як мінімум, 11 важливих інфраструктурних об’єктів у 8 регіонах і Києві,
частину областей знеструмлено.
Правитель Білорусі Олександр Лукашенко заявив,
що він і президент РФ Володимир Путін
домовилися про розгортання спільного регіонального угруповання військ.
Як заявив Лукашенко на нараді з питань безпеки,
розгортання такого угрупування викликане загостренням
"на західних кордонах Союзної держави".
В Кремлі назвали вибухи в Україні частиною
так званої "спеціальної військової операції",
утім багато хто називає цю атаку реакцією
на суботній підрив Кримського мосту.
Міст, який поєднував Росію з анексованим українським Кримом -
символ незаконної окупації півострова.
Усе сталося за кілька годин після ювілею Путіна.
На думку західних експертів, для Росії атака на Кримський міст -
важкий удар як символічний, так і військовий.
Це - кульмінація серед українських успіхів і російських невдач.
Атака на міст має як символічне, так і військово-стратегічне значення.
Символічно, тому що цей міст відображає претензії Росії на владу,
на володіння Кримом. У військово-стратегічному сенсі -
це важливий маршрут постачання військової техніки,
палива та особового складу.
Про символізм і чи не сакральність цього мосту для Путіна
говорить і військовий експерт Майк Мартін із Лондона.
Цей міст відкривав особисто Путін.
Це справжній символ для нього.
І руйнування мосту сталося саме тоді, коли й так у Москві
починають маневрувати, лунають звинувачення на адресу військових,
групи "Вагнер", особисто Путіна, так звана гра у пошук винних розпочалася.
І такий символічний удар українців ще більше посилить те, що відбувається.
Офіційно Київ не взяв на себе відповідальність за інцидент.
Український президент у своєму щоденному зверненні
лише наголосив, що на Кримському півострові 8 жовтня було хмарно.
Сьогодні на території нашої держави був непоганий і більшою мірою сонячний день.
На значній території - 20 градусів тепла та сонячно.
На жаль, у Криму було хмарно. Хоча і теж тепло.
Але якими б не були хмари, українці знають, що робити.
І знають, що наше майбутнє сонячне.
Це майбутнє без окупанта. На всій нашій території, зокрема, і в Криму.
Радник голови офісу Зеленського Михайло Подоляк спочатку у твіттері заявив:
Крим, міст, початок. Усе незаконне має бути зруйновано,
усе вкрадене - повернуто Україні, усе російське окупаційне - вигнане.
А згодом припустив, що вибух був організований Міністерством оборони Росії.
Нібито, таким чином відомство Шойгу кидає тінь на ФСБ
і перемикає увагу зі своїх невдач на фронті.
За версію російських посадовців, вибух вантажівки на Керченському мості організований Україною.
Американська газета New York Times, посилаючись на анонімного високопосадовця,
пише, що атака на Кримський міст була організована спецслужбами України.
Майк Мартін вважає, що за атакою може стояти лише Київ.
Це Україна. А хто ще?
Але насправді таке вже було й раніше.
Ви пам'ятаєте удари по російських авіабазах у Криму
та по складах постачання. За стилем вони схожі на удари по кримському мосту.
Це були не ракетні удари. Ймовірно, це були атаки спецназу або партизанські атаки.
Україна відкидала свою причетність до них.
В принципі це те, чим займається Росія протягом 20 років.
Якщо щось відбувається, то Росія каже:
"Ми не знаємо, хто це зробив".
В якомусь сенсі українці просто роблять так само, тобто відтворюють дії росіян.
Вони зробили щось, це точно вони.
Але потім вони кажуть: "О, ми не знаємо, хто це зробив. Хто б це міг бути?"
Російська армія продовжуватиме руйнувати
житлові будинки та інфраструктуру в Україні,
вважає Ґергард Манґотт, оскільки на полі бою Росія не може дати адекватної відсічі ЗСУ.
Я думаю, що після того, як тиск на військове
та цивільне керівництво Росії в останні тижні значно посилився,
з'явилося багато розмов про брехню, про "потьомкінські села", які є російською армією.
Чи може Путін не завдати жорсткого удару у відповідь?
Ймовірно, це будуть неядерні удари по критично важливій інфраструктурі в Україні.
Він не може залишити це без відповіді.
А якщо говорити про наступ на полі бою,
Росія зараз відповісти не в змозі.
Єдине, що залишається, це атака на критичну інфраструктуру.
Кремль використовуватиме підрив Керченського мосту
в своїх інтересах, впевнений політолог Микола Петров.
Путін сьогодні загнаний у кут, і очевидно,
що наступним його кроком буде завдання якомога болючіших ударів
уже не по українській армії, яка переграє в контрнаступ росіян,
а по цивільним особам і цивільній інфраструктурі.
Масована ракетна атака РФ на Україну в понеділок
вже викликала засудження європейських політиків.
Утім, чи отримає Україна додаткове сучасне озброєння?
Ґустав Ґрессель вважає, зараз для цього - найкращий момент.
Цього тижня має відбутися чергова зустріч міністрів (у форматі "Рамштайн")
щодо оборонної підтримки України, і я сподіваюся,
що попередні обмеження на постачання зброї Україні будуть зняті.
Раніше протиповітряна оборона не надто обговорювалася,
у цьому європейці та американці були досить відвертими.
Щодо можливої заміни українських винищувачів на західні -
все ще є перепони. І, звісно, щодо деяких наземних бойових систем, зокрема БМП, бойових танків.
Речник німецького уряду Штеффен Гебештрайт повідомив,
що термінове засідання Великої сімки, присвячене ракетним ударам Росії
по території України, відбудеться у вівторок, 11 жовтня.
На терміновому засіданні виступить і Зеленський.